[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number 39
is it that's right oh my god 39 yes we
took
saturday off it was our anniversary and
so we did
anniversary stuff and it was hot
it was it was hot but it was just really
really it was really hot yeah
so hot but um but anyways also pretty
hot i mean you know marriage gets a bad
rap but i love it and i love you so
that's just awesome and i love it and i
love you too oh
isn't this a interesting moment that we
are now doing with
several thousand of our closest friends
all right indeed um
in any case we are uh we are back to it
and there's of course
no shortage of things going on it being
2020 the democrats are up to their
democrat
thing they're doing it over zoom because
that's the new face-to-face
um we are also watching events unfold in
portland things
long predicted that are now manifest in
our streets
so maybe we should start there portland
yeah let's talk a little portland let's
talk a little portland
yeah so uh as uh most viewers and
listeners will no doubt be aware
on sunday night there was a an event
in downtown portland in which a
uh a driver was
pulled from his car my understanding
is that the driver was actually the
driver
driver who was male was actually
protecting
a trans woman he was then attacked
and chased through the streets of
portland he got in his car drove away
and was chased by what appeared to be
protesters and then
crashed his vehicle at which point he
was dragged from the vehicle
savagely beaten to the point of
unconsciousness he survived and he is
i believe still in the hospital
recovering
yeah so this this happened
uh people will no don't remember that
the feds were pulled out of
portland what is it going to be two
weeks ago or so
and right yep uh and
sorry i'm not sure what's going on here
okay
um the feds were pulled out a couple
weeks ago
i'm just i guess i thought that you sort
of had this i don't
i don't have the timeline exactly well
the
uh i mean there are still federal
officers here but
their increased presence was decreased
on the agreement that the local and
state police were going to
enforce the law in their stead thereby
creating a kind of
absurd reversal of the narrative um
as if this was a win for
for governor brown and mayor wheeler of
oregon and portland respectively
uh when in fact what had been promised
was that the local and state officials
would do what they should have been
doing in the first place
which was keeping the peace right
right so uh dhs was pulled out
with the promise that the state and
local officials would step in and do the
jobs that they should have been doing
all along
and um of course they have they have not
been allowed to
mostly they have they have been
hamstrung and they are mostly mostly
absent it appears and this is not um
presumably because they are interested
in being absent because they have
stopped wanting to do their jobs it's
because
the mayor and the governor believe that
the people who are yelling most loudly
in the streets represent
a majority of us and i am quite certain
as i believe you
are as are the many many people who are
uh in portland or um just in oregon
whom we've heard from that this is not
true this does not reflect the majority
at
all that the loudest that the loudest
people who are
screaming for uh defunding of the police
and a breakdown in social fabric do not
actually represent
uh what most people want um in fact i
was talking this morning with
um a woman who
who says of herself that she she just
loathes trump so much that she really
she has a hard time even
seeing even being able to see it when he
does something right as you know and
this is this
this is a real phenomenon um it is it is
you know good on her for recognizing
that she has
uh this trait but she can say
that and be you know thrilled about what
the democratic
democrats have on offer and also say of
portland
it is such a shame it is so
horrifying what is being allowed to
happen to our city and this is a woman
who is a native portlander she's
rahish and she was born and raised here
as well and has been here and has
raised her children here as well and uh
yeah i was i was down there
early yesterday morning i was downtown
early yesterday morning
and you know took a walk and saw
one thing that we've been saying um
throughout which is that
um the protests turn into riots after
dark
right the thing the thing doesn't happen
at all times of day
but even in the early morning what you
could see was
the vandalism almost all the storefronts
downtown boarded up
the just incredible amount of trash
like even basic city services have been
suspended
the homeless encampments they're not
only growing but are becoming
more chaotic more trashed
and the other thing that i saw which was
which maybe saddened me the most was
what appeared to be
a number of store keepers shopkeepers
who were out on the sidewalks cleaning
up the mess from the night before
so there were this is a place that
hasn't seen rain in a while and
you could walk from a street that was
filled with trash
and dry and dusty and just you know
just really disgusting in terms of
level of cleanliness and then you'd come
upon a scene
in which all of the sidewalks were wet
and there was an
old an old man you know or
or a woman with a hose or with a rag
scrubbing or hosing and cleaning off
clearly what had happened the night
before and in this case the night before
was in fact the night
where this horrible beating happened
and so we have a situation in which
you've got a
tiny number of people who are reliably
breaking the law nightly and this is you
have
certainly heard people claim this is a
mostly peaceful protest which is a
nonsense claim
in light of the fact that the violence
breaks out utterly reliably
night after night so you what you have
is
a riot with an on-ramp every night
and the costs of that are increasingly
being
born by citizens who are
attempting to make a living in the midst
of this occurring
the city which is supposed to make that
possible by
enforcing the law evenly is not
enforcing it
well at all and certainly not evenly
that is to say
all you have to do is um mouth certain
pseudo truths in order to
evade the law and you know the costs are
going to fall arbitrarily on the rest of
us
and the thing that i just can't get over
is that this is actually reshaping
cities
we see many cities now involved in the
process of quote unquote
defunding their police and predictably
enough
you've got a massive rise in crime as if
anything else could possibly have been
the product of this
there's no reliable measure at all
of how many people actually want their
police defunded and so it's kind of
like an amplitude thing there are some
people in the street who say that that's
what they want
and so the governmental apparatus is now
acting as if that's representative which
it obviously isn't nor did they make any
attempt
to figure out whether it was and the
consequences
are predictable ghastly
getting worse at an amazing rate and yet
currently last month had the highest
homicide rate in portland of any
month in 30 years and
how was it supposed to be otherwise i
mean
it was just clear that this would be the
result
of effectively advertising that policing
is now
suspect we want less of it of course
that's a beacon to anybody who wants to
engage
in crime to settle scores whatever it is
that they're doing this was simply
inevitable
yeah no i mean we've we've talked a
number of times before
about what defund the police might mean
what it could mean
the modern bailey switch that people
pull who like to trot it out and when
they they will then claim that no we
don't mean abolish we just mean
move some of those resources away to
social services cetera
but we've also said a few times but
maybe less
that one of the obvious effects
of taking money away from the police in
advance of
fixing other societal problems
for whom the police are there to respond
will of course make things worse and
will make policing
worse faster right what we need what
i think almost everyone can get behind
is we always want better police no
matter
how good they are we want better police
and better police and no matter how good
the police currently are policing
currently is
and the way to get better police is not
to pull money out
we want to attract the best people
if you start at this moment
who who 10 years ago or 20 years ago or
30 years ago
even five years ago who might have been
interested in being
a police officer is going to look at the
state of policing the united states and
say ah
yes that's the job for me i think i can
do good there
there will still be those people that
minority of people
who go into policing or try to go into
policing
for uh for motives that are that are bad
um those people aren't going to be
deterred by this presumably
who are going to be deterred are the
good people the
the good future police who are exactly
the people who we want on the streets
now there's a lot else to be done you
know we need
we need better training we probably need
more
um in urban centers more cops on on the
beat on the streets as opposed to
patrolling in cars
there are a number of things that have
been suggested as ways to
reform and you know in some cases get
back to some of the better policing of
of past eras
and move forward to better policing the
future but
the way to do that is to actually put
more resources
towards policing such that we can get
crime under control and then and then
hopefully
we can move towards less
i of policing agree with that and have
said similar things but i want to go
even one step further yeah which is
if you remove the resources that
currently
fund the police if you reduce the number
of police
on the street the result will be
more brutal policing that in fact
brutality is a substitute for resources
that in effect
if a smaller force needs to maintain
order what it will do
is it will wield weapons more
aggressively in order that the penalty
that people
experience for breaking the law goes up
so that you don't need more police and
so
this is certainly going to increase
exactly the problem that the protesters
claim that they are responding to which
is the brutality it will decrease
non-lethal force but it will not
decrease overall use of force
it will decrease non-lethal force
relative to potentially
lethal force i i i'm increasingly loved
to even use these distinctions i think
the point is
if you don't like brutal policing then
underfund them
that's how you'll get it and frankly i
don't even know wait i
i feel like you reversed a sign there
you want to say that again if you
i don't know what i did say what i meant
to say was
if you um want brutal policing
underfund the police right that that
that is an automatic and that it from
the point of view of this
movement that is potentially exactly
what they want because really
this movement isn't about policing this
movement is about
power and resources and the
justification for it is that the police
are so dangerous to people from certain
racial groups that they have to be
abolished because there's nothing else
you could do
and so if you want to create brutal
arbitrary policing and then
broadcast those instances against people
from certain racial groups and say c
told you then this would be the way to
get there so
now we have yeah i i honestly don't
i don't know how portland gets saved and
i'm i'm i'm pissed i'm i'm angry at this
point we moved to this beautiful city
um that has so much promise and you know
really i mean you
you actually proposed to me a day or two
ago you know couldn't
couldn't portland replace the other
dying west coast
cities as a destination for some of the
wealth that is being honorably generated
uh in for instance san francisco
and you know it's it is such a gorgeous
culturally rich culinarily rich natural
resources rich
place and at the moment it is it is
falling apart and what do we have we
have
a a weak mayor who has done
nothing to to impress himself on
us in any way and his main contender to
the throne come november
is someone who actively declares herself
antifa
pro-antifa and has been photographed in
a skirt with pictures of
lennon and mao on it i mean like this
these are the contenders for the mayor
of
portland it's insane it's insane
but you know the really depressing thing
about it
is that um okay this is very childish
this is um the dumbest version of
marxism
that has ever taken over anything
and yet the there have been some pretty
dumb versions nope
i don't think there's ever been one this
time okay this is
so incoherent and the things that it
says are so far
from plausible that i think actually
just in terms of the stupidity of the
claims the implausibility of the claims
this one takes the cake um so to speak
but
um but there will be no cake there's not
going to be any canal um
but they could eat it and have it if
they want it
in any case the the irony here that i
see
is that you know we are in touch with
some
large sample of
the smartest people in the english speak
speaking world
they don't know what to do people are
fleeing
the major cities they're talking about
the collapse of civilization they don't
have
a clue how to counteract this you and i
who i think are doing
as much as we can are frankly
increasingly
looking into a camera and saying how
could anything this dumb wield this much
power i mean we know that the answer
resides in game theory but nonetheless
you would imagine that given the ability
to see what's coming
and how dangerous it is and the frankly
um ghastly threat that it constitutes
to the west not just the u.s but the
west
writ large that we would somehow be able
to coordinate a response
around how do we prevent this from
happening how do we address the
frustration
in a way that does not take the rug out
from under
all of the structures on which we depend
so that we don't have a power vacuum
that
allows the russians the chinese who
knows who
to flood in and in effect govern the
planet
yeah so at some level
it is amazing how impotent the
uh would-be adults are in the face
of these children throwing a tantrum and
i i really don't understand why that
conversation is not taking place the
conversation is so much about the
tantrum and so little
about what the proper response to a
tantrum that threatens to disrupt
everything
is we are not having that conversation
no we're
i mean some of us are but the fact is i
mean this this is a point that
that you have been making for decades
really is that
these kinds of things sneak in in clever
packaging
that with the rise of consultants
and pr firms and publicity managers and
being on brand and all of this
um that that we saw through basically
the second half of the 20th century
you increasingly have movements that are
savvy
to human psychology sufficient whether
or not the people who are saying the
things know what they're doing
it really doesn't take that at all in
fact it may be more powerful if they
don't know
the effect of what they're doing all it
takes
really is putting together the right
sound bites and so you know we have been
saying and i
do increasingly hear and see people
saying online
you know when you say that black lives
matter do you mean to support the
obvious and true sentiment the black
lives matter lower case lowercase
m or are you referring to the movement
hashtag black lives matter
which is not what it seems and people
say this
but still still now it is it has fooled
a tremendous number of people
still now the the don't hurt me walls or
and you know placards are up all over
the place
and still now we have these weak mayors
weak governors saying oh yeah
probably it would be a good idea to get
rid of the task force that considers
whether or not gun violence
is an issue here you know it's
it's incoherent but what they are doing
is responding to words
as if words are truth and responding to
words
of words or truth is actually almost
like the flip of the
mistake that postmodernism makes where
you know postmodernism is like
there's no objective reality and your
truth is just as valid as my truth
and now we're saying okay but here i've
got this phrase
and because it uses these words the
thing
the words that it uses must be
reflective of what our goals are even
though
we're now just like don't look at the
man behind the curtain we're gonna go
back here and do whatever we're doing
while you shout about our phrase and get
more people on board
yeah i i see it but increasingly i don't
think this has
anything to do with words this has to do
with some sort of a tipping point
in which demographically speaking
something
as a result of kovid as a result of
shifts that have been in motion
over the course of decades is finally
in a position where if it all just
simply points in the same direction
it is in a position not to make anything
happen it doesn't have the capacity to
build
the people involved in it don't know
what to build they wouldn't know how to
build
building and making something happen
aren't the same thing well if making
something happen
is tearing something down that somebody
else has built then that is the thing it
is in a position to do
and the question
is i i think something has failed
in the would-be adult class is the point
and because the other thing because the
thing that we are up against
is so um
[Music]
difficult to ignore and fascinating in
its absurdity
we are not looking at ourselves and
saying how is it
that we cannot just simply level with
people and say
those people obviously don't know how to
run anything you can tell that they
don't
based on the fact that they say things
like defund the police and it's not even
taking months
just even the initial forays into
reducing policing are immediately
causing
crime waves they're causing uh you know
increase in the murder rate this is not
hard to detect that you know you can
just
test the hypothesis do they know how to
run a city
are they right that removing the police
will make things safer
clearly not we know that already right
so why is it
that we cannot now look at each other
and say
all right hypothesis tested
how do we stop them from wielding power
yeah well i mean
in part again the problem is also in
numeracy
i saw a comment on willamette week
today or yesterday uh discussing
wheelered mayor ted wheeler's suggestion
to maybe bring back a little bit of the
gun violence task force that was totally
eradicated
i don't know when a month or two ago and
one of the comments was
oh right like you think that this uptick
in
murders has anything to do with getting
rid of that gun violence task force
don't you realize we're in a pandemic
man
like okay like that it is certainly true
that being in lockdown for months helped
get so many people out on the streets
who wouldn't otherwise be on the streets
and in fact i've seen people admit well
you know what
i lost my job i don't see what's going
on in my future
so yeah i'm going to get out there and
protest with other people because what
the hell else am i
else am i going to do right so i do i do
think and we could
test that that is a real correlation but
it is also quite possible for people to
imagine that that thing that i just said
that
uh that aid
the highest murder rate in portland in
30 years which happened in july
is due to covet 19 lockdowns is a
plausible rejoinder to
the now actually much more recently than
coven 19 lockdowns actually
the police were told they couldn't do
their police work anymore
well the police were told they couldn't
do their police work and the police
were incentivized not to do anything
because to the extent that they do
anything and some
edit right a policeman who now makes a
mistake
of any kind runs the risk of it being
the next
catalyst for violence personal or
otherwise
and so so actually to pick up on that so
yeah
we are we are not downplaying the fact
that police brutality does exist and
that it should be minimized as much as
possible
which all police would agree with as
well
but anytime any policeman does
anything at this point that could be
understood
in a less generous light it will be
understood that way
and this reminds me of something that
your brother
had said to us as evergreen was blowing
up and
and uh and unfolding what he said was
as we're watching the protests
turn into riots on campus and just like
one crazy error after another by
these the people in charge there going
like surely the world will see it nope
the world would spin it and
you know and the mainstream media
wouldn't show up and we'd get one pr
story after
another but what eric said to us was
they're allowed to do all of that but
you guys aren't allowed a foot fault
there's there are no foot faults allowed
in this game
uh because the the media
the the mainstream narrative machine
which cannot understand people on the
left
going you know saying raising their hand
and saying actually you people don't
speak for us and you're not on the left
it doesn't it doesn't track and so they
were we were we were being watched
like hawks for any errors that we might
make
any evidence that we were not what we
appeared
right but the problem is we are now at
the point
where we are actually watching the
wealthy
flee the cities that they have turned
into personal playgrounds
and leaving them undermining
them by eliminating the tax base
um but uh you know
also just effectively abandoning the
rest of us who live in these
places and um i guess the question is if
you think about the effort
involved in picking your family up and
moving them
to wherever you're planning to go in
order to protect your family and believe
me i get the impulse
right if it were simple for us to do it
we would certainly have to consider it
but the effort
that is being put into people of means
moving their families out of harm's way
which they obviously see coming
is immense why is that effort not being
put
in to preventing this collapse in other
words it's the same failure of game
theory
at every level right you may be able to
move your family
out of a city that's in danger of a
collapse
that does not protect you from the west
collapsing and
china filling the power vacuum so in
some sense you are still
yes you may be acting to protect your
family
at the expense of the whole but you
can't protect your family from what
unfolds downstream of that this is the
same thing that happens when you
mouth the words you know
trans women are women in order to get
the mob to leave you alone
you strengthen the mob you survive into
the next day but the point is the
institution that you're part of
now is weakened and eventually topples
and you'll pay the price anyway so
i can't see why the
slightly longer term analysis about
where
your well-being is actually protected
does not persuade all of these people
who are obviously persuaded of something
very important if it's causing them
to actually load up their lives and put
their stuff in a van and go somewhere
right why it doesn't trigger the
kind of emergency response that i would
expect would exist in all of us
but what i mean i guess i'm not sure
what you're arguing it clearly is
triggering
their personal emergency response and
individuals
don't have the power of society to
change
policy and like i'm not sure what it is
that you are suggesting
i i i wish there was a different
response but i don't i don't know what
you're advocating for
well for one thing i would imagine um
that
watching the electoral slow motion train
wreck
unfold would not be something that
people just said oh
okay i'll vote for one of the standard
bearers because what else would you do
i would imagine that the people who do
have influence over these
entities would be utilizing it just
selfishly you would expect i mean look
people have
spent a tremendous amount of resource
corrupting our government
that means they have power over it they
could wield that power in the people's
interest
just cynically to stave off this
disaster
they won't do it why not whatever it is
that corrupted the government
has the power to stop this by liberating
resources that could actually be applied
in a way that would make sense
instead they're walking away and they're
moving their families
that does that doesn't make any sense
well i'm not sure i'm not sure this
works with what
what you just said about people walking
away and moving their families like i
don't i don't exactly know who
uh what that demographic is but at some
level if you're talking about sort of
generational level analysis that
um you and eric specifically have done a
lot of
uh it's you know the the boomers largely
um who have created a system in which
they are
uh corralling and concentrating much of
the wealth and it is their children the
millennials
who are increasingly the up-and-comers
making decisions that are
post-modern at best in places like
um like academia like the media like
tech
like everything really right so you have
that that sort of one-two punch with you
know the the
smaller generations of us gen x and uh
you know our
rising gen z kids coming up
um without as much voice because we just
don't have as many numbers
and because the boomers were the last
generation to really concentrate wealth
in a meaningful way
that um those with wealth are protecting
it they may
presumably be um helping out out the
kids to some degree and
and you know not all of them like we we
taught
mostly millennials for 15 years and
almost all of our
students were frankly remarkable and
highly capable whether or not they came
in highly capable or recognizing their
capabilities or not but
frankly they they were terrific and so
you know i don't mean to slander an
entire generation just as you know just
as not all boomers this and not all gen
x that right but
uh to a large degree it is not the gen
xers nor the gen
zers who are so confused about the
nature of male versus female
or uh you know or any of this other
garbage that we are being expected to to
accept
in the name of this sort of
intersectional
woke ideology
yeah i guess i mean i i don't know maybe
i'm just
you know i'm now zach could you put up
the uh the article on new york
so this article was published uh
it was self-published um
this week and it makes a very compelling
case
that a many people maybe a million
already
have fled new york city as a result
of a couple of different things one of
them is that
kovid revealed in some sense that a lot
of the jobs
the highly prized jobs in new york can
be done from anywhere
and so there's no real reason to be you
know gathering in midtown
it forced remote work in a way that
people maybe couldn't force their
employers
to it before right and so um you know
people are
discovering that you know there's a lot
of downside to living
in new york but people who love it
people who you know have made the most
of the cultural opportunities
that it provides and you know the great
restaurants and all of that
are fleeing in droves right i mean and
you know
art arts and theater are
not happening for the foreseeable future
we're missing that here too
the restaurants are closing first
because of covid
but you know at least in portland i
can't speak new york but
restaurants were closing shutting down
despite trying
everything they could to to persist and
then
just as they were being able to come
back open then
uh protests happen and the protests
quickly turn into riots
and vandalism and looting meant that
either the
the resources themselves were damaged or
people just don't want to go down
down to eat in places where there's
gonna be nightly violence
of course they don't yeah i mean i guess
i'm trying to put my finger on exactly
what i'm feeling and i'm definitely
feeling something
um you know it's not just ominous i mean
we've known that for
years we've seen this coming but i think
i'm feeling um
i'm feeling betrayed yeah i'm feeling
like
the people who often speak the loudest
about the magic of the market and what
it has allowed them to accomplish
and the need for personal responsibility
because given a market
you can wield personal responsibility to
self-betterment at an extraordinary
level
the people who say this
are now abandoning ship
knowing full well what's coming for
those of us who aren't in a position to
do it
and my feeling is actually we deserved
better
you know you and i have suffered from
the accusation that we somehow fueled
this post-modernism
from the beginning there's never been
any truth to it right you and i have
been
literally fighting this since we
ourselves were college students right
we didn't generate this and yet we also
nor facilitated it we didn't generate it
we didn't facilitate it we fought it all
along
um we however did not
make maximum use of the market right
we've made a living we've done well
but we have not generated enough wealth
that we can just pick our family up
and go and so why exactly is this going
to fall in on us
it's totally foreseeable we've been very
clear and i think we've been courageous
about pointing out what the hazard was
you know even when the hazard was very
specifically targeted at us and not
general and people belittled us for
making too much of it right and so i
just i
i just betrayed go go on i'm feeling
like
i'm seeing various different flavors of
a failure
of patriotism right there's a massive
failure of patriotism on the left which
is of course
well known right the left likes to
demonize the country but
it isn't all of us on the left some of
us are very clear on what's great about
the country and we want to see it
democratized so that it reaches
the maximum number of people right but
then people elsewhere maybe not so far
on the left who have been very um
aggressively uh selling the idea
of the the magic of uh the market and
the opportunities provided here
do not appear ready to defend
the structure other than kind of online
where it's cheap right and anyway i
guess
um i mean this leads to a lot of things
you know we are
hearing a tremendous number of people
who
you know 10 years ago would have been
you know prominent in the uh gun control
debate who are now buying guns and
frankly they're rational to do it
we've certainly done it um but the point
is
i think the second amendment debate has
ended and there's been no
acknowledgement
that the
argument that firearms are actually a
hedge against
tyranny which is the correct argument
that
maybe the founders didn't see this
particular version of tyranny coming but
that in a general sense there was
something true about that argument
that you know i don't know if the second
amendment debate is over but i sort of
have the sense it is based on the number
of people
who have bought firearms knowing that
civilization is
more fragile than we understood and that
they may need to defend themselves
i don't think so unfortunately and i
don't have the story pulled up so i
won't be able to find it quickly but um
there's some case being brought i think
in a new york state
court uh to abolish the nra
right and you know the nra is not the
second amendment but um
but the that argument will continue
well i i'm not so sure that it has that
much fuel because
the you know what that argument requires
is a great many people
um behind it and to the extent that
people i mean
i also don't have the the data to bring
up but
gun sales have gone through the roof
twice now in
you know in less than a year right we
saw it at the beginning of covet and
then we saw it
at the beginning of the george floyd
protests
so i think the thing is we are watching
people
register their personal incentives
in ways that are measurable one of them
has to do
with gun sales and i mean either people
are completely hypocritical and they're
not going to recognize
that their own instinct to buy
firearms undercuts their argument that
um
civilization depends on uh tightly
regulating them i mean you know look
i'm in both places here because i don't
want to see
uh you know i don't want to see the
proliferation of firearms that are going
to result in
uh lots of lethal violence on the other
side
i mean you you and i i and i think you
do hold both of those positions
i think that you know wanting regulation
and tracking of guns is
not uh inconsistent with understanding
that gun ownership is written into our
constitution
and is something that actually many of
us can increasingly see a need for
i don't see how these are inconsistent
positions well it depends what version
of the gun control
argument you're going to level i mean i
agree we have to have
regulation you're not allowed to have a
nuclear weapon
so therefore it is true that your right
to bear arms is inherently going to have
to be limited and that means we have to
draw a line
somewhere but the line is usually about
um personal firearms and the thing that
has never existed on the
gun control side of that debate is an
acknowledgment
of the interaction between
firearms and tyranny in other words
the prevention of tyranny is something
that the right very frequently says
about firearms and the left
pretends it's not a real argument um and
i think people are now discovering in
their own lives that as
uh the forces that maintain
civil order begin to break down they
fear tyranny and anarchy and that they
see this as somehow
relevant so um i'm not saying
there obviously has to be uh rational
regulation
but what that rational regulation
involves and what price people are
willing to pay for it seems to me
will have changed as a result of what
people are discovering
true um let's see there were some other
things
i was just going to suggest that we
segue to
uh some of the ideology that is uh
cryptically and not so cryptically at
base of the movement that has taken to
the streets
um that that most people watching
will be less intimately familiar with
the
actions happening on the nation's
urban streets at the moment and more
familiar with the kinds of
diversity inclusion and equity trainings
that are coming to an office near you if
they haven't already
so i forgot to look up which episode or
a couple of episodes
we talked in some depth about robin
d'angelo's white fragility
and i'm not prepared to do a complete
takedown of
ibram x kendi's how to be an anti-racist
just yet because i've only gotten
through
i don't know a third of it um but i want
to talk a little bit
about about this because this you know
because because the author of this book
is a black man unlike robin d'angelo
who's a white woman
um her book has begun to fall out of
favor apparently in some of these die
diversity inclusion equity trainings and
his kendy's book
is becoming more popular and in fact
he's you know he's he is a rising star
as he has been for a while
he's on uh he's on the cover of this
month's the atlantic
uh with a um an article called the power
of american denial
and so i just have a couple of excerpts
not the usual excerpts i try to read
excerpts that are
enlightening in some ways and i do not
find
rea anything about what i have read of
his stuff enlightening but it's
important for us
for us all to know what is being said in
in part
because just like d'angelo has redefined
what racist
means uh and the the way that you will
hear
people saying to you well if you're a
white person you are inherently racist
that that comes mostly out of the
d'angelo
playbook well candy framed this like
you're racist
or you're anti-racist and that is a
complete solution set like that is his
framing
and uh just like black lives matter
uh and and other feel-good
sound good phrases of course you want to
be anti-racist
obviously especially if the only other
option on the table
or allowed by your humanity is to be
racist of course you choose anti-racist
now he
unlike d'angelo gives us a choice right
like you can actually
aspire to be non-racist i'm not sure he
ever lets you there so that we still
have this sort of
original sin issue um but let me just
um use his words to define
what he means right so from from this
september
2020 issue of the atlantic he says this
is candy
from 1977 to 2018 the general social
survey asked whether black americans
quote
have worse jobs income and housing than
white people mainly due to
discrimination
candy writes there are only two answers
to this question
the racist answer is no it presumes the
racist determine that racist
discrimination no longer exists
and that racial inequities are the
result of something being wrong with
black people
the anti-racist answer is yes it
presumes that nothing is wrong or right
inferior or superior about any racial
group so the explanation for racial
disparities must be discrimination
in 2008 he continues as obama was headed
for the white house
only 34.5 percent of respondents
answered yes
a number i will call the anti-racist
rate
this was the second lowest anti-racist
rate of the 41-year polling period the
rate rose to 37.7
in 2010 perhaps because the emergence of
the tea party forced a reckoning for
some white americans
but it fell back down to 34.9 in 2012
and 34.6
in 2014. so
he has defined um
just to i have more quotes here but
um what he has done here is said
that um once again the actual question
being asked for the general social
survey
is do black americans have worse jobs
incoming housing than white people
mainly due to discrimination
there are only two answers to this
question now of course that question
is itself a whole bunch of questions and
you might legitimately say well i don't
i can't answer that question that
question is too many questions
already right but kendy puts that aside
he says
no actually either yes it's mainly do
discrimination in which ding ding ding
you win you're an anti-racist or at
least you're aspiring to be
or no i think that some
other explanation is also in play here
no you lose you're a racist these are
the only two possible
answers um that that he will allow for
so
i would point out also that this while
well candy as far as i know
isn't uh involved in the sexism binary
part of the
uh intersectional movement it's all the
same group
and um guess what they're wrong on both
fronts
like sex is a binary like male and
female are real and that's what we have
and have for
500 million years but disparities and
outcomes between racial groups
that's not a binary disparities and
outcomes between racial groups
undoubtedly has a strong explanatory
variable in historic racism and
some explanatory variable in current
racism but the idea that it is the only
thing that you are allowed to consider
else you have demonstrated that you are
racist is
not a legitimate rhetorical tactic but i
will say this for candy he is an
excellent
uh what would it be rhetorician
rhetoric guy um i'm not sure he's he's
very smart he's great with language he's
uh i'm sure he could write and talk
circles around d'angelo
who's much simpler to to get rid of
um so just to point out a few more of
his definitions
um from his from the book from how to be
an anti-racist
um there are three more places where he
sort of defines his new coding of racist
versus anti-racist
one if racial discrimination is defined
as treating considering or making a
distinction in favor or against an
individual based on that person's race
then racial discrimination is not
inherently racist
the defining question is whether the
discrimination is creating equity
or inequity if discrimination is
creating inequity
then it is racist he then goes on to say
if discrimination is creating equity
which is to say equal outcomes that's
what equity means equal outcomes
then it is anti-racist so discrimination
that creates equal outcomes is
anti-racist
this is why you should and could and
absolutely
must really strive to be not anti-racist
certainly not racist but not anti-racist
either because
that's ridiculous two uh
from page 20 of his book there is no
such thing as a not racist idea
only racist ideas and anti-racist ideas
so what is a racist idea a racist idea
is any idea that suggests that one
racial group
is inferior or superior to another
racial group in
any way three from
even like marathon running well that's
we're getting there oh okay
uh page 64 to be anti-racist is to view
national and transnational ethnic groups
as equal in all their differences
to be anti-racist is to view the
inequities between all racialized ethnic
groups as a problem of
policy so uh i thought we might discuss
a few examples of people of european
descent being worse
or more susceptible to things um and
using candy's
examples then we're clearly engaging in
racism when we talk about europeans not
being as good at something the
obvious example as you just pointed out
brett is um
marathon running so so zach if you want
to
show this briefly this is a 2012 article
from the atlantic the very same
once great monthly publication that is
now putting
this kind of ridiculous thinking on its
cover why kenyans make such great
runners a story of genes and cultures
it's quite a good article um from it
i'm not sure if i can find zach if you
want to give me my screen back um i'm
going to read
a uh a
excerpt from this article which finds
which which doesn't find this article is
not a piece of original research which
uh points to the now well-known finding
that kenyans are better and it's not
just even africans per se but kenyans
are better at long-distance running and
that canyons and ethiopians
is the uh yeah you know it's actually
it's not as clear
apparently for ethiopians the uh the
finding uh the statistical
finding for kenyans is it's much more
clear and in fact it seems to be a
particular tribe within kenya okay
so here we have an extended quotation
from this 2012
atlantic article it turns out that
kenyan's success may be innate
two separate european-led studies in a
small region in western kenya which
produces most of the race winners
found that young men there could with
only a few months training
reliably outperform some of the west's
best professional runners
in other words they appear to have a
physical advantage that is common to
their community making it probably
genetic
the studies found significant
differences in body mass index and bone
structure between the western pros and
the kenyan amateurs who had bested them
the studied kenyans had less mass for
their height longer legs shorter torsos
and more slender limbs
one of the researchers described the
kenyan physical differences as bird-like
noting that these traits would make them
more efficient runners especially over
long distances
surprisingly the 2012 atlantic article
continues
western popular writing about kenyan's
running success seems to focus less on
these genetic distinctions and more on
cultural differences
for years the cultural argument has been
that kenyans became become great runners
because they often run several miles to
and from school every day
but about a decade ago someone started
asking actual kenyans if this was true
and it turned out to be merely a
byproduct of western imaginations
14 of 20 surveyed kenyan race winners
said they'd walked or ridden the bus to
school
like normal children do another cultural
argument says they run barefoot which
develops good habits but if this were
true then surely the far more populated
countries of south asia
where living without jews is also common
would dominate over kenyans
another ascribes it to the quote simple
food of kenya but this again is true of
many
other parts of the world and kenya's not
so great health records suggest the
country has not discovered the secret to
great nutrition
and there is a cringe-inducing theory
still prevalent that kenyan's history as
herders mean they get practice running
as they chase their sheep across the
countryside
so i mean i think there's a lot to be
said here
but one of them is one of the things to
be said here is that all of those
cultural hypotheses that are apparently
preferred in the western press
are themselves pretty freaking racist
right they like they smack of this old
school cultural anthropology
which was like okay we're going to come
in on our you know our
our white anthropologists on our white
horses not that anthropologists tend to
ride in our horses but
um and you know and save you from
yourselves and you know point out
how um your your pre-industrial ways
actually make you better at some things
but you know unspoken wink-wink probably
not so good at some other things so you
know that's actually
some so anthropological racism built
into those
those stories about you know the culture
being the reason
that these canyons with let's see less
mass for their height longer legs
shorter torsos and more slender limbs
are doing better uh at breaking marathon
records
uh than uh people from other parts of
the world
yeah i'm not sure i find i mean i find
those um
anthropological explanations tone deaf
and ignorant
i'm not sure i find them racist but um
we also have to be a bit careful here
because the physiological
and morphological differences between
populations are large and they account
for things in the real world that have
nothing to do with discrimination
right in fact discrimination has denied
advantages
to people who would have been superior
at sports until they finally broke into
them so we've seen that in
boxing we've seen that in uh baseball
we've seen it in tennis um and you know
the
the fact is those differences are real
they are based
in trade-offs right so
it is the fact that different habitats
select for different things
that result in different populations
playing different sports better than
others
that does not inherently have any
implication
whatsoever for cognition could there be
differences in cognition there could be
but they are much
less likely and so what i'm troubled by
is that the examples that we have to
resort to in order to prove that the
logic that candy is deploying here is
faulty
because we can see very clear examples
in which physiology and morphology
explain something that has nothing to do
with racism and does generate the
pattern proving there's a third category
of explanation right
but that suggests that what we're saying
is wink wink
that same third category is what
explains differences in success between
populations
when in fact that probably does have a
lot to do with historical racism
which doesn't say anything about modern
racism and so
i again i'm feeling just a bit hopeless
because the real problem with his
argument
is that almost nobody has
the patience and
the knowledge set to be able to go
through it and see exactly where the
little logical errors are that have
these gigantic effects on the conclusion
right so you have to be able to spot
those things basically at some level
i feel like all of us need to spend
a week going through these arguments and
figuring out
which part of them is true which part of
part of them is faulty what implication
it has for the
the conclusion because otherwise we're
going to tear civilization apart over
the fact that
most people do not know how to take
apart candy's argument
right um so we i mean we've got
um we've got kenyans being better at
marathon running
uh at the at the disease level so you
know we have said
race is a bastardization a
messy imprecise at best inaccurate
very very often if not always
representation of a real
genetic and evolutionary concept called
population right
and we can see with regard to disease
also that there are distinctions between
between groups tay sachs is is
concentrated among ashkenazi jews
right sickle being homozygous for sickle
cell anemia
is concentrated among african americans
within
north america right so those are
observations that are borne out
by by the testing that is accurate
and in candy's rubric
pointing out that those accuse those
observations are
true is itself a racist act
so um to pretend that they're not true
would be the only way forward to be
anti-racist
which is obviously not a tenable
position to stand on right you there's
like the foundation is
is really unstable um
in in do you have something to say
yeah i i just wanted to point out that
in part
this argument is built it's not about
logic
it's about power and you can tell it's
about power because it's so categorical
right and so the the right challenge to
it is something like
let's imagine a situation in which
some group of violent
white identitarians are kidnapping
black people and killing them right
where the explanation
is 100 racism
it is still not correct in that case to
say the only possibility
is this in other words the idea that a
logical argument
requires as you point out it requires a
complete solution set
of answers that could be right even when
there's no currency to one of those
answers it still exists as a
formal possibility and any argument that
says the formal possibilities that
aren't an important player in the story
are no longer formal possibilities
is about ruling them out for reasons
that aren't logical they're about power
right and so you know and the fact that
he
he's defining and this is now spreading
throughout all of these diversity
inclusion and equity
workplace trainings that many of you
have had to have been forced to sit
through
that he is defining um the solution set
as racist versus anti-racist and
anti-racist
is in he's not ambiguous about this
it requires equal outcomes
for any group that you could define any
group
which also means you can just create
your own group and say ah
i'm underrepresented because i just
created myself and you know well
i don't find myself over there so you'd
better hire me because i need to be
represented there
yeah it's a loophole i can invent a new
gender my gender is one that
oscillates between male and female i
spend two thirds of my time male
one third of my time female and i just
reverberate back and
i i have bad news for you oh i don't
think that's a new gender oh i think
it's been done
to say yeah um
all right that's a little hard to know
how to come back from that but well you
could you could
publicly for the first time here
announce what your actual
pronouns are the pronouns i use
for myself and why are me and i yeah but
with regard to the part of orca that you
identify as oh i definitely identify as
a part of orca
and uh why is that again
is that because it it it gives voice to
my black and white sides i don't know
something yeah yeah yeah you're adult
and you're juvenile you're yeah
and the yang enough of this playing with
these very dangerous concepts
um but yeah yeah well actually so um a
few more things from the book
and then um i have something that a
teacher a public school teacher who had
to sit through some faculty and staff
training
in the last couple of weeks uh sent me
uh in which
supposedly um you know which is built on
all of this d'angelo candy style
thinking um but just you know other
things that he says in this book
um he explains he takes some time to
explain why pre-modern islamic slave
traders were not pursuing racist
policies
um all right it's gonna take me a second
well yeah it would it should take you a
long second actually i'll just have
a very long second i did not see this
coming
no no no no uh he says
uh pre-modern islamic slave traders like
their christian counterparts in
pre-modern italy
were not pursuing racist policies they
were enslaving what we now consider to
be africans arabs and europeans alike
at the dawn of the modern world the
portuguese began to exclusively trade
african bodies
prince henry's sailors made history when
they navigated past the feared
black hole of cape bohador off western
sahara and brought enslaved africans
back to portugal
so i'm sure that he would not say that
he was being an apologist for slavers
who weren't
being slavers in a racial way but it
certainly seems like that's what he's
doing
he's he's focusing on racialized
by which he actually means just you know
geographically focused
um and you know elsewhere in the book he
makes it clear that actually geography
isn't race that race is not real and so
you know he's
he's going back and forth between all
sorts of arguments and being
inconsistent
um but uh he makes a point
of sort of excluding the pre-modern
islamic slave traders from
his ire because they were equal
opportunity slavers or something
so that's that's that's one thing
and so you know he obviously points out
the flaw in his own argument
which is that even in the case of a
completely racialized
slave trade you don't know that it would
have been if the geography
had been distributed differently yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah so a couple pages
later he
talks about um linnaeus um
who as we know is biologists and as many
people who remember their high school
biology will remember
um was the guy who first tried to start
categorizing
um life on earth with these you know
binomial binomial species names
like homo sapiens uh felicil after
celestia so that's true sylvesterous
canis domesticus
or cans familiaris canes familiaris
that's humans domestic cats domestic
dogs
um and illinois was as as
we know actually you know very confused
at one level he
he called it uh he identified as scala
nachouri in which you were
ascending to become better and better
and better and humans were
were the top uh and candy focuses on
linnaeus
um did not restrict his hierarchical um
strange and and misguided thinking to uh
species out to to things outside of
humans but he also had a hierarchy of
races
themselves which is of course racist and
also not at all surprising and totally
in keeping with the rest of what he did
um so i don't know if candy ignores the
fact that linnaeus was
consistently hierarchical and not a good
thinker in this regard
because he doesn't know what happened or
because it serves his argument
that you know the history of western
science is racist well
in this case it's a you know it's a
classic example because
linnaeus is pre-darwinian and so
the fact is linnaeus didn't know that he
was
interfacing with a world in which all of
these
different co-existing species were
actually
co-existing from a shared ancestry and
therefore the scala nature doesn't make
any sense
um so uh you know the point is okay
if you analyze linnaeus in the context
in which linnaeus existed
you get one answer if you decide to go
after linnaeus on the basis that we now
know enough to understand why he was
being
um foolish then okay what have you
accomplished really it's retrospective
bigoteering
it's a retrospective bigoteering yep
exactly
okay one more uh one more point from
from candy before
uh we move on to our final thing and
then it looks like we're over an hour at
this point
um he uh
ah he points out let me actually find
the quote in here
this is page 50 in this book um
at the 1988 american heart associate
association conference he writes a black
hypertension researcher said african
americans had higher hypertension rates
because only those
able to retain high levels of salt
survived consuming the salt water of the
atlantic ocean during the middle passage
i've bounced this off a number of
colleagues and it seems certainly
plausible clarence grimm told swooning
reporters
plausibility became proof and the
slavery hypertension thesis received the
red carpet in the cardiovascular
community in the 1990s
graham did not arrive at the thesis in
his research lab it came to him as he
read roots by alex haley
who needed scientific proof when a
biological racial distinction can be
imagined by reading fiction
by reading the bible so there is
so much wrong with that passage right
one
candy appears to basically be taking the
possibility of selection on human beings
off the table
as ever being an explanation that we are
allowed to speak about
so it's fundamentally a religious
position that he is that he is
advocating for
um he clearly misunderstands what
science is because the
idea that a researcher got a hypothesis
from a source that wasn't in his lab
while wearing his white lab coat and
handling glassware is of course where
that's that's what that's what
hypothesis
is ideas are creativity they do come
from serendipity they do
come from people actually exposing
themselves to ideas far
and wide and being in places that they
haven't been before and not foreseeing
what it was that they would find
hypotheses are then tested through
careful
rigorous observation or experimentation
depending on exactly what your test is
and what the hypothesis was
and i don't know if this has actually
been tested this hypothesis
but it is an evolutionary hypothesis
that is um that is at least plausible at
the level of
did the middle passage have selective
effects on the populations that were
so grotesquely ripped from their
homelands and enslaved
yes because we know large numbers of
people died
during the middle passage it would be
frankly extraordinary if there had been
no selection
then is that honorable is it good is
that wonderful in any way no no one is
making that claim
but kendi is taking off the table the
possibility of an evolutionary
explanation
for any differences under any
circumstances it appears which means
we're just you know he has stripped us
of all of our tools
right so again the stripping
of the tools is clearly the point
and somehow you either get this or you
don't
you either take all of these arguments
about
arithmetic not you know being a
white thing and shut down a stem because
of its
inherent racism or whatever you either
understand that
all of this is about eliminating any
basis on which you could object to a
claim that justifies a transfer of
well-being
that's really the point transfer of
well-being is the is the objective
and that transfer of well-being is being
justified on the basis of things that
are either not completely true or not at
all true
and in order to prevent them from being
exposed as false you have to get rid of
all the bases on which you might
establish their true
their truth or falsity such as
logic such as science such as statistics
and that's what we're facing it these
things are not under attack
for no reason or out of some sort of
incoherence it's
absolutely a coherent plan about
transferring
well-being in the pursuit of something
that is ironically being
called equity which is nothing like it
and frankly the
fact that equity well it is but
unfortunately it is because equity
doesn't mean what we think it means
right right and this this is another
place where are you well of course i'm
anti-racist of course i
stand for black lives matter of course
i'm for equity like
no you should 100 be non-racist and also
non-anti-racist you of course should
understand that black lives matter but
not hashtag black lives matter unless
you understood everything that that
movement is actually standing for
and actually equity is not the same
thing as equality and the people who are
trying out equity as the goal know that
very very well
so what that what that means to them is
equality of
outcome but it doesn't even right that's
the claim
the most generous interpretation of what
they're saying is equality of
outcome but the point is even equality
of outcome
assumes some ability to measure when it
is equal and when it isn't as stupid as
it would be
to pursue equality of outcome
obliterating the standard by which you
might
judge when it has been reached means
that this is just
transfer it all to me now because
equity will be reached when i say it's
reached and you know it'll be reached
never they tell us that yeah right this
was frequently said at evergreen and
i've seen it seen
repeated many times since we left which
is this job will never be done
yeah right it's just going to be a
continual process of transfer
and you know that's unstable insane is
going to create you've got to keep all
those administer new administrators
salary don't you oh god
you traumatized me you should give me a
trigger warning if you were going to
mention administrators
i'm sorry okay one last thing
um a uh a a viewer
uh who is a teacher at a public
i can't remember high school middle
school who was forced to sit through
some diversity inclusion equity training
shared some slides that they were
they were shown this week and uh there
were there are a number of them there's
some real doozies in here
but two of them speak to and you can
show this now if you would zach
the idea that uh some people are more
monochronic
and some are more polychronic in their
approach
to to life monochronic apparently
meaning you know linear
and focused on on doing one thing at a
time and polychronic well
let's see kind of just sounds like
i don't even know like what what could
that possibly mean
i don't know it's it's it's multi it's
supposed to be and actually here we go
um here's no uh yeah so emphasis on
multitasking
interruptions are okay for the
polychronic and the non-linear
uh work and personal is combined in this
case
um and for the monochronic it's about
punctuality and work and personal life
separate so literally in this training
in which uh which is supposed to be this
you know
anti-racist diversity equity inclusion
training
they are claiming that certain
populations are more likely to be
monochronic versus polychronic
and um apparently what i'm told by the
person who had to sit through this
is that this is given as a reason um
that maybe people from certain
backgrounds should
not be expected to respond to deadlines
and schedules the same way as other
people
which is obviously completely racist
and is also completely the opposite
of anything that candy would say
qualifies as anti-racist
furthermore this idea of monochronic
versus polychronic which
is just a very strange way of
to my mind of imagining how people are
going through the world but you know are
there differences and you know between
people in terms of
uh in terms of their understanding of
time and might some of those differences
be cultural
maybe and in fact this this harks back
to
apparently a um see if i can find it
um i didn't write it down here
an essay by an anthropologist from many
decades ago in which he proposed that
some cultures
actually have less of a focus on a
linear sort of mono
unit asking time and some cultures have
more
focus on multitasking you know maybe
it's possible
but that's about culture it's not about
people right so the idea that african
americans
who've grown up in america with their
supposed you know monochronic sense of
time
would have something genetic that is
feeding them
a different sense of time and scheduling
is
actually that's like that's kind of old
school racist is what that is that's not
even the new racism that's old-school
racism
well it's um it's
thoroughly confused so i
must say i actually think the weird
thing here
is uh what i would call clock time or
laboratory time
these are not normal features of human
time keeping and that the thing is the
human
brain is amazingly capable of keeping
track
of time both at like musical scales
and um daily scales
in the absence of clock time the brain
does remarkable things
with time and it is very non-linear and
then
we invent a reliable clock which is of
course useful because it means you can
tell somebody
you know meet me there at this time
and that's a very valuable thing to be
able to do but nonetheless what it does
is it regiments time
to an arbitrary phenomenon
which is real but the
arbitrary version then imposes itself
on the rest of it in other words your
day
might change in length as the day length
changes right because
that's a perfectly re it's not an
arbitrary fact
the fact that daylight is something that
you make use of means that as there's
less of it during the day
it may in fact make quite a bit of sense
to sleep longer so that you're not
burning energy pointlessly
so we create clock time and suddenly
you're getting up in the dark and
confusing
yourself and having trouble going to
sleep when you should because you've
arbitrarily disrupted this thing so what
i would argue is that
every population is liable to have had a
flexible relationship to time
based on the fact that time you know uh
it only gets it all regular if you're
very near the equator for one thing
right
length yes um so the uh
you make the right point which is i
would expect these things
to be flexible at a cultural software
level it may indeed be the case at some
point maybe pre-industrial
post-industrial
it could be pre-industrial positions
pre-globalization post-globalization
personally be
that in some neighborhoods clock time
matters more it could even be
that what they're calling polychronic is
contagious because in a neighborhood
where people
i mean you know we joke about this when
we travel island time is different right
in many places you know you can you know
in madagascar
right like i i believe we once waited
days for something that was supposed to
come within a few minutes
absolutely no for sure we did boats taxi
bruce oh all the time on gamba repeats
could be a week from now right but i'm
going to tell you maybe tomorrow so
that's a kind of don't want to kill off
open time decreased obligation to clock
time but anyway the point is look
there's every reason that different
populations would have a different
relationship
it's quite possible that some of the
different relationship is actually
different as a result of the fact that
in a racist past society
different things were were rewarded
but is there any reason to expect that
to be encoded
at the genetic level no no no way
no i mean no way you could
have tropical populations for example
uh have less sensitivity to day length
because it's less of an indicator of
what time of year you're in i mean you
know it's
possible but there's no reason at all to
assume that that's where these things
come from especially since the clock is
so freaking new that to the extent that
some of us
are rigged around a regimented clock in
which a second takes about a second
every single time
um that that uh that that is the novel
phenomenon that has been imposed over
the top of all of these other
potentially more um practical versions
of
relationship to time yeah so i mean at
some level it's possible
once again that there's some like kernel
of
like recognition that there's a problem
with the system that most of us are
having to live by
and an appeal to fix it but this appeal
comes in this crazy racialized
uh interpretation that can't be right
and wouldn't be
like wouldn't be a reasonable fix if it
were but
you know when we've got our teenagers
getting up
at the same moment that is for most of
the year before it is even light out if
we're really far from the equator in
order to go to school to
learn something that has nothing to do
with the thing they're going to be
learning in the next 50 minutes
like none of that looks anything like
our past nor
does really yeah i haven't i have yet to
meet
the deep thinking good faith person who
thinks that that's the best way to
educate kids
i just it does those people don't exist
um there are people who haven't thought
about it much whose
knee-jerk reactions oh yeah must be good
it was how it's always been done
um but deep thinking good faith people
know that this is not the way to educate
children nor um is it likely to be the
best way to get the best work out of
people
when they have to get ups uh for much of
the year if they live far from the
equator
before it's light out and get themselves
to work and pretend
that it feels the same in december as it
does in june
when they've got some light on their
skin from you know getting to
to work because it's near the summer
solstice versus the winter solstice
it's it's patently not the same and
pretending that we can simply
make you know every day of the year the
same much like pretending that we can
make every human being the same
just because we want to uh isn't going
to be effective
so i think the take-home message uh for
me from this conversation
is that everything goes to hell as a
result
of the categorical nature of the claims
now there are claims that are
categorical
right the periodic table of elements is
a categorical claim about the way matter
is composed at the level of chemistry so
i'm not saying there are no claims that
are categorical but the kinds of claims
that are being made categorical
are deranging us because they are not
inherently of that type
so the idea that well i'm going to
assert that there are exactly two
categories there is racist and there is
anti-racist and then i'm going to
evaluate everything and tell you which
basket it's in when there's another
category that obviously should exist
means that we can't have a rational
conversation because we
we have dichotomized something that
isn't dichotomous and
imagine the difference in the world if
we were actually in
a conversation in which the idea was
okay i'm going to say something
everything is either racist or it's
anti-racist do you
agree or disagree and we'll find out
what category
you're in right it's like okay that's a
trick question yeah right
every satanic game show it's a satanic
game show right
and so the point is look at the point
you sign up for that
you've already lost yeah because you're
going to be forced into a category which
is either going to turn you subservient
as a result of the fact
it's going to dictate your actions or
you're going to be declared the
stigmatized thing and we're going to
take your stuff
yeah so you either you put up a don't
hurt me while as you realize that you've
fallen in one of those categories
or you flee for the hills yeah yeah
all right well i think that's useful
yeah i think that is useful too
actually uh the the deranging
categorization of things that are not
actually ripe for categorization good
yes okay okay um so we will take about a
15-minute break
and um and come back after that to
answer your superchat questions from
this hour and from next hour and a
couple from
the last episode you can join us
on my patreon to get access to a private
q a once a month
and you can join us on either our
patreons to access the private discord
server
um there's a clips channel with clips
of these episodes and did you want to
give any unity updates or not
yet um there will be unity updates
upcoming we have a new animation that we
would like to
show you and have you spread it around
if you were at all willing
things are marching ahead in the land of
unity and uh the democrats have in fact
taken the word unity which we are
flattered by
and have decided to abuse it by using it
for partisan purposes which we are
dismayed by
but anyway uh unity is on the mark it's
likely to be confusing isn't it
it's already confusing yes all right
we'll see you in 15 minutes
be well thank you